hi my name is Mike LaRon I'm an engineer
on the Android development team Android
is an open software platform for mobile
development it is intended to be a
complete stack that includes everything
from the operating system through
middleware and up through applications
in the next few minutes I'm going to be
introducing you to an overview of the
architecture of the Android platform and
I'm also going to talk about some of the
key principles that are underlying its
design we're going to talk about
architecture we need to start with a
diagram covered with a lot of little
boxes and this is ours our architecture
we're going to start at the bottom work
up architecture is based on the Linux
2/6 kernel we use the Linux kernel as
our hardware abstraction layer so if you
are an OEM trying to bring up Android on
a new device the first thing you do is
bring up Linux and get all your drivers
in place the reason we're using Linux is
because it provides a proven driver
model and in a lot of cases existing
drivers it also provides memory
management process management a security
model networking a lot of core operating
system infrastructures that are robust
and have been proven over time the next
level up is our native libraries
everything that you see here in green is
written in C and C++ it's at this level
where a lot of the core power of the
Android platform comes from I'm just
going to go through and describe what
some of these components are I'm gonna
start with a surface manager the surface
manager is responsible for composing
different drawing surfaces onto the
screen so it's the surface manager
that's responsible for taking different
windows that are owned by different
applications that are running in
different processes and all drawing at
different times and making sure the
pixels end up on the screen when they're
supposed to below that we have two boxes
OpenGL ES and s GL and these two make up
the core of our graphics libraries
OpenGL ES is a 3d library we have a
software implementation that is hardware
accelerated if the device has a 3d chip
on it the s GL graphics are for 2d
graphics and that is what most of our
application drawing is based on one
interesting thing about the Android
graphics platform is that you can
combine 3d and 2d graphics and the same
application moving over we have the
media framework the media framework was
provided by packet video one of the
members of the Open Handset Alliance
and that contains all of the codecs that
make up the core of the media experience
so in there you'll find mpeg-4 h.264 mp3
AAC all the audio and video codecs you
need to build a rich media experience we
use free type to render our fonts we
have an implementation of sequel light
we use that as the core of most of our
data storage we have WebKit which is the
open source browser engine that's what
we're using as the core of our browser
it's the same browser that's powering
Safari from Apple and we've made some
we've worked with that engine to make it
render well on small screens and on
mobile devices next is the Android
runtime and the main component in the
Android runtime is the dalvik virtual
machine the Android runtime was designed
specifically for Android to meet the
needs of running in an embedded
environment where you have limited
battery limited memory limited CPU the
the dalvik virtual machine runs
something called Dex files de X and
these are byte codes that are the
results of converting at Build time dot
class and jar files so these files when
they are converted to dot Dex become a
much more efficient bytecode that can
run very well on small processors they
use memory very efficiently they the
data structures are designed to be
shared across processes whenever
possible and it uses a highly CPU
optimized bytecode interpreter the end
result of that is that it's possible to
have multiple instances of the dalvik
virtual machine running on the device at
the same time one in each of several
processes and we'll see why that's
important a little bit later on the next
level up from that is the core libraries
this is in blue meaning that it's
written in the Java programming language
and the core library contains all of the
collection classes utilities IO
all the utilities and tools that you've
come to expect you
moving up again we now have the
application framework this is all
written in the Java programming language
and the application framework is the
toolkit that all applications use these
applications include the ones that come
with the phone like the home application
or the phone application it includes
applications written by Google and it
includes applications that will be
written by you so all applications use
the same framework in the same api's
again I'm gonna go through and talk
about what some of the main components
are in this layer in the application
framework the activity manager is what
manages the lifecycle of applications it
also maintains a common back stack so
that applications that are running in
different processes can have a smoothly
integrated navigation experience next
down from that is the package manager
the package manager is what keeps track
of which applications are installed on
your device so if you download new
applications over-the-air or otherwise
install applications
it's the package manager that's
responsible for keeping track of what
you have and what the capabilities of
each of your applications are the window
manager manages windows it's mostly a
Java programming language abstraction on
top of lower-level services that are
provided by the surface manager the
telephony manager contains the api's
that we use to build the phone
application that's central to the phone
experience content providers are a
unique piece of the Android platform
that's a framework that allows
applications to share their data with
other applications we use that in our
contacts application so that all of the
information in contacts phone numbers
addresses names is available to any
application that wants to make use of
them and other applications can use that
facility as well to share data the
resource manager is what we use to store
localized strings bitmaps layout file
descriptions all of the external parts
of an application that aren't code I'm
just going to touch lightly on the
remaining four boxes view system
location manager notification manager
and XMPP service the view system
contains things like buttons and lists
all the building blocks of the UI
it also handles things like event
dispatching layout growing location
manager notification manager and XMPP
service are some API that I think will
allow developers to create really
innovative and exciting applications and
the final layer on top is applications
this is where all the applications get
written it includes the home application
the contacts application the browser
your applications and everything at this
layer is again using the same
application framework provided by the
layers below now if you're going to
write an application the first step is
to decompose it into the components that
are supported by the Android platform
here are the four major ones we have
activity intent receiver service and
content provider and activity is
essentially just a piece of UI typically
corresponding to one screen so if you
think of something like the mail
application that would be decomposed
into maybe three major activities
something that lists your mail something
that shows you when an individual mail
message and a compose screen to put
together an outgoing email an intent
receiver is something different an
intent receiver is a way for which your
application to register some code that
won't be running until it's triggered by
some external event and the set of
external events that triggers your code
is open and extensible so you can write
some code and through XML register it to
be woken up and run when something
happens when the network connectivity is
established or at a certain time or when
the phone rings or whatever trigger
makes sense for your application
the next major component is a service a
service is a task that doesn't have any
UI that's long-lived that's running in
the background a good example is a music
player you may start playing some music
from an activity from a piece of UI but
once the music is playing you'd want it
to keep playing even if you're
navigating to other parts of the user
experience
so the code that's actually running
through the playlist playing songs would
be a service that's running in the
background you can connect to it later
if you want to from an activity or some
other component by binding to the
service and sending it messages like
skip to the next
or rewind the last component is a
content provider and again that's a
component that allows you to share some
of your data with other processes and
other applications now any application
can store data in whatever may way make
sense for that application they can
store it in files they can store it in
our sequel light database whatever makes
sense but if they want to make that data
available as part of the platform so
that other applications can make use of
it then the content provider is a
solution for that and we've used that
for the contacts database that comes
with the Android platform so that any
application can make use of the
information in contacts Android was
designed at a fundamental level to
encourage reusing and replacing
components I have an example here that
shows how that works on the left there
are four applications that might want to
pick a photo for some reason so the home
application might want to pick it for
wallpaper contacts might want to pick a
person's face to associate with their
contact card Gmail or MMS you might want
to have a photo that you send to someone
in an outgoing message now an Android
for these applications to make use of
the service of taking a photo they first
need to make a request so the client
component makes a request for a specific
action in this case I'm illustrating
that with a clock bloom and the Gmail
application is requesting that it picks
a photo so the talk balloon is actually
a representation of a formal class in
our system called an intent what the
system does when a request is made is it
looks at all of the installed components
and it finds the best available
component that knows how to do whatever
was asked for in this case let's say
that the system finds the built-in photo
gallery now what happens is the Gmail
application is now connected to the
photo gallery when the user in Gmail
wanted to pick a photo he will be taken
to the photo gallery the photo gallery
will fulfill what whatever was asked for
in the intent what makes this
interesting is that the picking of the
matching component is late bound it's
done very late and so you can swap
software components at any time so let's
say you didn't like the built-in photo
gallery and you wanted to replace it
with one that went online
to find a richer or bigger set of photos
you could replace our built-in photo
gallery with one that say goes out to
Picasa or whatever your favorite online
photo site is once you've done that then
any of the applications on the Left will
now use the new and better component on
the right to fulfill the task of taking
a photo and at any time a new
application can come along and make use
of existing functionality so if you're
writing a blogger application you don't
have to worry about writing a photo
picker yourself you can just rely on
whichever one the user has configured to
be their preferred photo picking
application this becomes really
important because in Android it's not
just about picking photos virtually any
task has an intent in the middle if the
user is going from point A to point B
there's an intent in the middle and each
of those intents is an opportunity to
reuse a component or to replace a
component so we have intense for going
home which means you can replace a home
application or we have an intent for
sending an email which means you can
replace the mail application all of
these are opportunities for replacing
and reusing components if you're
interested in finding out more about
Android I encourage you to visit the
developer site and download the SDK in
the SDK you'll find a lot more
documentation and sample code and you
will also be able to try building
applications of your own there's also a
developer group that you can join to
find out more information and I also
encourage you to check back frequently
because we'll be posting updates to the
SDK as the platform matures thank you
for watching